el presidente ruso vladimir putin vería
de una forma favorable que ucrania
entrase en la unión europea si
permitiese y si prometiese no formar
parte de la otan así lo ha explicado
este jueves por la mañana el presidente
turco de recep tayip erdogán que está en
pleno contacto con su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin como también lo está con
su homólogo ucraniano volodymyr james
que de hecho erdogán ha explicado este
jueves que está intentando conseguir que
sea lenski putin se encuentra en un cara
a cara a poder ser en turquía ha dicho
el presidente turco y que turquesa
haciendo todo lo posible para que ambos
líderes se reúnan y puedan tomar
decisiones más drásticas para terminar
ha dicho erdogán con esta guerra en
ucrania conseguir un alto el fuego
permanente que termine con esta invasión
rusa de algo hace algo más de un mes que
empezó sobre ucrania también ha hablado
este jueves por la mañana el ministro de
exteriores turco mevlüt cavusoglu que ha
explicado que turquía está trabajando
para que los dos ministros de exteriores
ruso y ucraniano se reúnan otra vez para
continuar
con las negociaciones que avanzaron
significativamente el pasado martes
también en estambul entre las
delegaciones de ambos países ha dicho
abuso lo que espera que en la semana que
viene o la siguiente puedan dmitro culé
va al ministro de exteriores ucraniano y
sérguei lávrov y su homólogo ruso
reunirse otra vez a poder ser en turquía